identify the most reasonable units to
measure the weight of the choices below
so we have an average adult a slice of
bread a kitchen table or a pack of gum
so I am an average adult and I know that
I weigh about 160 pounds so I know that
pounds are pretty good measurement for
about something the weight of an adult
so I'll put adults in that category
right over there now we have a single
slice of bread so even a full loaf of
bread doesn't weigh a lot maybe that
gets close to a pound but a slice of
bread is going to be less than a pound
so I would do this in I would do this in
ounces a kitchen table well a kitchen
table kind of weighs the same it could
if it's a very large kitchen table could
weigh the same or more than an adult so
I would do this in pounds and then a
pack of gum so once again a pack of gum
is fairly light if you ever been to the
gym and held even a 1 pound or 2 pound
weight it weighs more than a pack of gum
so a pack of gum is going to be less
than a pound so ounces seem to make
sense here